guys if you want to transform your style
easily quickly and cheaply change your
hair
I'm GQ style editor will Welch and these
are the hair product secrets of GQ
staffers I grab my trusty comb and what
I'm trying to do is is I'm trying to
like find a parting which is something
that I know to do because I've seen my
barber do it the reason I really like
lay right is because it is very very
strong and if you have hair like mine
which is very very wavy and thick it
does a really good job holding it but it
washes out with just water it's not like
greasy now are there any like funky
spots on your head that you have to
watch out for Roy
yeah it's mainly funky spots do you run
your fingers through your hair through
the day or you kind of don't touch it
will actually actually do one more I do
one more thing which is I comb it again
this is why it's sort of like looks a
bit like a rockabilly you don't carry
that comb in your pocket all they do
definitely do not carry the comb like
this for Jared so I leave my bike again
like just good we meet up down by the
corner just yeah you know it will look
like this for the rest of the day which
is a good thing and I think the reason I
like it is because it is very
low-maintenance right
it's clear so it's a little hard to see
but I I sort of rub it on my hand a
healthy portion yeah I do they say that
it should be you know like about a dime
or a nickel but I go from more of a
susan b anthony dollar um and then i
just run it all through my hair like
this really try to get deep down into
the roots of it if there's any left on
my hands I've I've messed it up I take a
comb and I use the fat end of the comb
and I like to part it a little more than
I'm comfortable with naturally would be
down here but I sort of brought the part
in from here I sort of go simultaneously
back and up the problem is you get these
kind of fly away in there so you got a
sort of tame those and as soon as you
get it right you gotta leave it it takes
no time but it just it looks like I made
an effort
the guy that it's my hair actually like
puts putty or some sort of paste in my
hair but it's a little bit heavy it
looks great when you like does it in the
salon but then when I leave for us to
follow or where it's like to take a sad
willow tree yeah as I keep pushing it
back right so this one it's a pomade
mousse so it's a little bit lighter and
it's easier to like work into the air
it's kind of rub it between my hands and
then start like putting it in where the
front where it's really heavy my hair
tries to go that way so I try to like
push it back a little bit yeah some
flyaways on top this part is like kind
of problematic so those look tricky so
yeah that was we got to show us what
that technique was yeah I just kind of
like kind of rub the product in motion
rope I don't know sometimes it doesn't
work now it works all right yeah I
learned some new stuff with this
especially the solution real solution of
towel dry my hair as much as I can and
then I use styling cream a little goes a
long way this is the primer coat yeah
primer coat this is all over get it sort
of where I want it and then I blow dryer
this side tends to stick up a bit yeah
and so I you know put pressure on it
there and in the back - I have a cowlick
back here so it'll you know sometimes
stand up as well it's a little high
maintenance but this is what I have to
do and I kind of curl it back a bit
Oh roll that isn't managed don't like it
then the me only gets just a hair mama
again put some on the sides to tame the
sides because my hair ten states
straight up right have a slight part but
you know keeping it loose still right
that's about it pasted there yeah
actually do this sour time
like any good surfer you're doing what
exactly alright guys that's it if you
got any style questions for GQ leave
them in the comments and we'll see you
next time